مساء الخير لم يكن لديه هذا الاسبوع
الحديث عن ولكن كل الاحداث وزني الى
التركيه والرئيس التركي سواء كان الاعداد
حلقه عن ما يجري في اوكرانيا والنزاع ما
بين الاوكرانيه وروسيا اخذني الى هي
الحديث عن سوق الطاقه اخذنا الى توفير
اعداد حلقه للاجابه عن اسئله تعليقات بعض
الاصدقاء من حضراتكم اخذنا ايضا الى تركيا
واحد هذه الاسئله هو تعليق من الصديق
الاستاذ محمد في السي اي اللي كتب في حلقه
احد التعليقات الموجود على حلقه كيف نفهم
العالم
المخلوق الوحيد الذي لا يمكن ان تفهمه هو
الرئيس التركي هو الحقيقه هو قال القرض
العثماني لكن انا طبعا يعني احتفظ
بالاحترام الشريط للرئيس التركي كما نحترم
جميع الناس لكن تفاعل مع صديقنا محمد عدد
كبير من الاصدقاء ومن خلال مائه واربعين
تعليق مختلف خلاف اسئله اخرى في هذه
الحلقه حلقه كيف رفع بالعالم بحلقات اخرى
سابقه
الحقيقه لما اتفق محمد ان الرئيس تركوا
المخلوق الوحيد الذي لا يمكن ان نفهم ان
الرئيس التركي كتاب مفتوح
سياساته مفهومه تماما
ونقدر نخصص الحلقه في محاوله لفهم الرئيس
التركي وممكن يكون جزء من عده حلقات نفهم
فيها الدول الاقليميه في المنطقه الغير
العربيه تركيا نتكلم عنها معارضه ايران
اسرائيل بيساعدنا جدا في فهم خريطه العالم
هدفهم الرئيس التركي بوضوح لازم نرجع كم
سنه لورا وممكن تقول البدايه من سنه الفين
سنه الفين وواحد تمت عن احداث 11 سبتمبر
وعمليه القاعده في ضرب الولايات المتحده
بعد العمليه كانت صادمه جدا للولايات
المتحده
تحولت الاداره الامريكيه
الاسلام باعتباره عضو رئيسي وكان في
اتجاهين رئيسيين في الولايات المتحده
اتجاه يقود الحزب الديمقراطي واتجهت يقود
الحزب ال
الاتجاه اللي بيقود الحزب الجمهوري كان
راغب في عقاب الدول اللي بتعتبرها الدول
الاسلاميه تعتقد انها مصدر الخطر عليها
وتغيير دول اخرى تعتقد انها قد تكون مصدر
فيها يعني اعقاب افغانستان عقاب العراق
لقاء وتغيير انظمه اخرى ممكن تبقى مصدر
خطر عليها سوريا
الحزب الديمقراطي كاليه تصور مختلف
وهو انه الافضل اعاده النظر في سياسات
الولايات المتحده في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
هاملتون تشكلت على مطار ستين سبعين سنه
وانه الافضل ان احنا نقيم علاقات طيبه
ايضا على الناس ونبحث عن حلفاء جدد خلاف
الجنرالات العسكريين او الملكيات اللي
الشارع مش راضى عنها يعني ما كان تشهدها
الحكم مبارك ولا زين العابدين ولا الرئيس
اليمني الى اخره الى دول اخرى وبالتالي
ولا حتى في رده كثير عن بعض الملكيات اللي
ماكانتش ادري اذا كان عندهاش بترول ان هي
تقدر ترد الشعب الرؤيه دي قامت على فكره
يكون البديل هو الاحزاب او الجماعات
الاسلاميه الى الامريكان اعتقدوا انها
تملك الشارع والشرعي التعاطي معها وهذه
الجماعات في المقابل هي جماعات حليفه
للولايات المتحده
فكره الحزب الديمقراطي كان اهم مرور ليها
هو حزب العداله والتنميه
والرئيس هدفين اردوغان اللي كان في رحله
صعود وبدايه من الفين وواحد الفنون الفين
وثلاثه وكان صاحب هذه النظريه هو اهم منظر
في السنوات الاخيره للسياسه التركيه وزير
الخارجيه التركي رئيس الوزراء السابق احمد
داود اوغلو شخصيه مهمه جدا وكتب ونظرياته
اثرت كثير
كثيرا في تركيا وفي منطقه خلصت النظريه
اللي بيعتبرها بغض النظر عن كل التفاصيل
التركيه اللي بيقول طيب اربعون بغض النظر
عن صاحب النظريه قدر يقنع الولايات
المتحده وقدر يقنع الحزب الديمقراطي على
وجه التحديد
بان الاسلام ليس هو القاعده وان الاسلام
ليس هو حتى ايران ولكن ال غالبيه من
المسلمين مسلمين عنده بيول معتدله وان
الميول المعتدله دي تمثلها جماعات على
راسها جماعه الاخوان المسلمين بغض النظر
عن اسمها وانه الاسلام بصفه عامه الاسلام
المعتدل هو حليف الغرب والولايات المتحده
وان الحل ليس جديدا من حلفاء قديم جدا
اولا هو كان حليفه لبريطانيا
ثمان حليف للولايات المتحده منذ ايام
المستويات الاولى للحرب البارده بعد بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وكان حليفها الاساسي في ضرب الاتحاد
السوفياتي الشيوعي الكافر
اذكرهم باحداث كثيره احداث كثيره استعانه
فيها الولايات المتحده
بالاحزاب الاسلاميه والدول الاسلاميه في
مواجهه الاتحاد السوفياتي ومنه الاجتماع
اللي عامله دون دالاس تنفست وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي في سنه ثلاثه وخمسين اللي جمع
فيه كثير من الاحزاب والجماعات الاسلاميه
ومنهم جماعه الاخوان المسلمين في اكثر
المختلفه في واشنطن
ودعاهم فيها وحش انهم لمواجهه الخطر
المشترك المشترك على الولايات المتحده
والقيم الغربيه والكامل اسلاميه وهذا تحدث
فيه واقنع الغرب انه ان الحل يبدا هو ال
ال الاسلامي يمكن ان يزدهر جدا اذا مكانا
له في السنوات على ان يحكم العواصم
الاساسيه في العالم العربي واقتنع قسم
كبير من
القرار في الولايات المتحده خصوصا في
الحزب الديمقراطي اللي هو كان هيلاري
كلينتون وكلينتون الرئيس ثم اوباما اللي
في فقرته بدا الثورات الربيعي العربيه
ثورات الربيع العربي كان اي م على توافق
امريكي
تركي على فكره انه يجب التخلص من
الديكتاتوريات العسكريه اللي موجوده في
العالم العربي
والبديل افساح الطريق
للتيارات الاسلاميه المعتدله اللي يرضى
عنها الشارع العربي وفي نفس الوقت هي
حليفه تماما من وراء الكواليس وامام
الكواليس او امام الكاميرات العالم الغربي
حتى اقتصاديه الولايات المتحده على اقتصاد
السوق المفتوح والجماعات الاسلاميه تؤمن
بسياسات السوق المفتوح فكل ما فيش اي
مشاكل و اي خلافات الخلافات ثانويه يعني
ما
عليه الرئيس التركي قضى سنوات طويله جدا
مع اقطاب ادارته اذا كان الرئيس التركي
السابق عبد الله غول او اذا كان وزير
خارجيته احمد داوود اوغلو اشتغلوا على
الفكره بشكل كثير جدا وكان فيه مصلحه
تركيا كبيره جدا للترويج دام عنها ببساطه
جدا انه
العصب النفوس كلها انتقل من القاهره
وينتقل من الرياض وهي كل موجود في انقره
النفوذ السياسي اتحول الى نفوذ اقتصادي
ويعود ب مغانم كثيره جدا على انقره انه
بيبقى بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
هي المعبر الاساسي الى الشرق الاوسط وهي
الوسيط الرئيس بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي
ربما يكون هذا الكارت او هذه البطاقه هي
البطاقه اللي بتثبت وتثمن وتعزز فرص
اردوغان للالتحاق بالاتحاد الاوروبي
باعتباره انه هو النافذه واهم يعني الوصول
الى الشرق الاوسط لانها يبقى تقريبا مش
يعني مقر خلافه بالمعنى القديم ولكن مقر
نفوذ العالمي الصيني
الغريبه انه فعلا ينجح بعد العشره ناشر
خمسطاشر سنه من محاولته في سنه الفين يعني
بعد حوالي احداشر سنه قدر ينجح في في
مسعاه فوجدنا مثلا انه في سنه 2012
وبدايه 2013 وجدنا انه احزاب اسلاميه صعبه
بالفعل الى اما الحكم زي ما حصل جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين في مصر او زي حزب النهضه
الاخواني في تونس والمغرب وليبيا واليمن
وطبعا حماس في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
وبالتالي اقدر اقول باختصار
الفين و
تلاحظ الانتصار بتصور
التركي او تصور الرئيس التركي المدعومه
امريكيا او الدقه يعني مدعوم بعض القوى
الامريكيه الى مباركه هذا المخاطر في هذا
العام بدات او يعني في العام التالي 2013
ثوره مضاده من القوى التي شعرت الخطر من
التصور التركي المدعومه امريكيا ا هل هذه
القوى بدات في مصر من خلال اللي هي ما
يمكن ان نسميه الدوله العميقه
المؤسسات الرئيسه التي لا تؤمن بهذا
التنوع صار فيه خطر عليها وخطر على بفتره
على الامن القومي المصري وعلى المنطقه
فكانت القوات المسلحه المصريه والجيش
المصري ان هذه الامن المصريه وزاره
الخارجيه المصريه
النقابات العماليه بعض القوى التقليديه
والعائلات اللي كان الداعمه للحزب الحاكم
الحزب الوطني يعني الدوله بمعنى اصح او
القوام الاكبر من الدوله عدد كبير من
الكتاب الصحفيين رجال الاعمال كما رافضين
للمخطط دوله بدا يظهر ياخذ شكل ثوره مضاده
فى 30 6
37 بدعم قوي جدا من دول الخليج كل دول
الخليج مع عدد او للقطر اللي هي بتدعم ال
وقتها جماعه الاخوان المسلمين لدول الخليج
كانت بتدعم مصر ليس حبا في مصر بمعنى انه
مساله اخويه لان الانظمه في دول الخليج ان
التصور التركي المدعوم الامريكيه ل يعني
اما نهايه هذه الازمه او وضعها تحت ضغوط
شديده جدا هي تقوم على فكره فكره القبيله
فكره الاسره فكره العشيره الانظمه دي زي
مثلا النظام في السعوديه والامارات
يتعارض طبعا مع وجود تمكين احزاب اسلاميه
اذا ما كان مثلا جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
عايزين يعملون في السعوديه والامارات او
غيرهم بان هي ان الحكم يقوم على
تبكيني هذه الجماعات من هذه الدول الدول
دي دعمت نقطه بدايه الثوره المضاده في مصر
اللي كان في المشهد يتزعمها السياسي
وبالتالي ابتدا
الاجهاض الاساسي المشروع اردوغان في مصر
ومنه انتقل الصراع بين التصورين دول
المنطقه في قول للملفات كما تحدثنا قبل ان
تختصر اردوغان سياسي او
المعسكر التركيه ومعسكر مصر في كل الاطراف
والاخرى كل واحد وحلفاؤه موجود قدرت لمسه
في كل الملفات كل الملفات لا تجد ابدا
اتفاق تقريبا بين القوه مصره على اي ملف
فتجد مثلا الصراع القائم على النفوذ
السياسي وبالتالي الصراع الاقتصادي على
فتح اسراع موت في ليبيا هما فين على طرفي
نقيض
الاسراع معمول في فتره من الفترات في
السودان زي ما شفته و رصدته اثناء اردوغان
للسودان في 2017 وهتلاقى برده في نفس
الوقت نعم اماراتي سعودي لمصر في مقابل
دعم قطري لتركيا في كل الملفات الخلاف
موجود على اثيوبيا تلاقي الخلاف موجود في
سوريا اعتقد الملف مون في قضايا تبدو
رمزيه زي مثلا الدعم ال مصر سعود
الاماراتي
لاتحاد حكماء المسلمين في مقابل الدعم
القطري التركي الاتحاد علماء المسلمين
الى خاص لكم الخلاف على كل التفاصيل
الخلاف كمان على المصالح الاقتصاديه
الكبرى وابرز هذه الامثله موجود في شرق
البحر المتوسط ايه اللي بيحصل في شرق
البحر
ده يحتاج منها حلقه ثانيه شرق البحر
المتوسط تركيا كان عندها تصور قديم جدا
يعني القضيه نسبيا بدا من الفين وسبعه
والفين وثمانيه ان هي بلد غير منتج للغاز
وكانت تامل ان هي من اذربايجان ومن دول
اخرى بدات ب اضربها جان اللي هي بلد منتج
للغاز تجيبوا الى تركيا بحيث يكفي
احتياجاتها وبعد كده هي تمد وخطوط اخرى
الى اوروبا
واحد بالفعل انها تعمل الخط الاولاني
وبعدين المؤخره نتفق مع روسيا اللي هي
اكبر منتج للغاز الطبيعي في العالم انها
انابيب عندها
المرحله الاولى شهرين ثلاثه الافاده على
ان تمتد هذا الخط الى باقي ربما فكره
تركيه باختصار لست منتج للنفط ولكن ممكن
ان اكون مصدر لتجاره الغاز في اوروبا
وبالتالي اكون كل محبس الغاز نتيجه من
الدول المنتجه روسيا اذربيجان واتفقت مع
اسرائيل بعد ان ظهر الغاز في اسرائيل انه
يجي الغاز من اسرائيل في خطوط انابيب
يمر الى اوروبا عبر تركيا كانت قطر كذلك
قد اتفقت معها منذ 2010 2010 الغاز القطري
وهي من اكبر الدول المنتجه يمر عبر سوريا
الى تركيا ثم الى اوروبا وبالتالي كانت
موحد تركي ان تتحول الى مر مركز لتجاره
الغاز وتحديدا في الجروب ده يعني عوائد
اقتصاديه ضخمه كما يعني تعزيز لاهميه
تركيا لاوروبا باعتبر ان كل المحابس اتحدى
في فتره من الفترات زي مثلا اوكرانيا اللي
كان الغاز الروسي بيجي الاوكرانيه ومن
اوكرانيا يوزع على مراقبون العالم الوضع
السابق الوضع ده مش بس انه توقف لمصر
اجهضت هذا المخطط وحلت محله تركيا وحبه
اصحاب المقدمه من عم تركيا
بمجرد ظهور الغاز في منطقه الشرق المتوسط
فكرت مصر انها تاخذ الفكره
وقالت انا عندي امكانيات اكبر من تركيا
كان عندها جهاز انا عندي الدول المنتجه
الرهيبه مني زي مثلا اسرائيل في قبرص
قريبين من ي فممكن يصب الغاز عندي وانا
عندي خطوط انابيب من اسرائيل وعندي
المسافه عند خط انابيب يربط
المتوسط الى اراضيه وقبرص واليونان مني
ممكن يوصلوا بدون تكليفه كبيره وكل الغاصب
عندي وممكن دول اخرى في المستقبل اذا كانت
سوريا ولبنان كذلك هي قريبه منه بدل ما
يروح والتركيه يبقى عندي وانا عندي اما
اننا اوصلت الغاز الى محطتين اساله
موجودين عن مش موجودين عندنا تركيا
وبالتالي اسيل الغاز اللي هي لا يصدر من
اراضيه او من الدول القريبه مني واودى الى
غروب غاز مسال او في المستقبل اعمل على خط
انابيب اخر يصل الى اوروبا وهي محفوظه
افضل من حظوظ تركيا لسببين السبب الاول ان
شركتين دولتين اوروبيتين منهم اسبانيا
ومنهم بيشتغلوا في مصر واحده منهم هي
اسبانيه عندها محقه اساله في مصر
والدوله الثانيه ايطاليا عندها الشركه هي
المطور الرئيسي للغاز في مصر والتنقير ان
الامر الثاني ان الغاز المصري الاسرائيلي
اللبناني السوري
القبرصي اليوناني حيكون بديل او يكون يعني
امر جيد بالنسبه الاوروبي لانه يكون تنويع
مختلف عن الغاز الروسي الاساسي اللي هو دي
من
عن طريق تركيا يكون غزو سامعه يا اللي
العتبات
انا عايزه اقول انه الخلافات التركيه
العربيه او الخلافات التركيه المصريه
المدعومه من السعوديه والامارات والبحرين
الى خلافات مصالح على النفوذ السياسي
والاقتصادي
ولا علاقه لها اطلاقا باي قيم اخلاقيه
محدده واذا اردت الدليل على ذلك بعض اتباع
الرئيس التركي بيروت عام دائما الاسبوع
على قرارات وطابعا اخلاقيا والحقيقه انا
بس انه يتفق مع مصالحهم
لكن لم ننظر للمساله نظره موضوعيه هلا ان
الرئيس التركي على سبيل المثال مثلا غير
دستور بلده بحيث انه يدعم مصالحه حتى وان
كانت تصرف غير ديمقراطي ان يسخر كل وسائل
الاعلام زي الدول العربيه بالضبط لخدمه
مصالح ان كل بكثير جدا من خصومه عشرات
الالاف بعد 2016 و خصومه لم يكونوا من
كفار قريش ولكنهم كان معظمهم من اتباع
الداعيه الاسلامي فتح الله غولن
وبالتالي المساله موقفه في سوريا القائم
على مصالح كامله وفيما يتعلق بالتوكيل
مثلا بالاكراد لانه يمثل الخطر من وجهه
نظره على الامن القومي سياسه بحثه ما اريد
ان اقول ليس ان الرئيس الرجعه ليس عنده
اخلاق وهو سياسي بارع يدافع عن مصالحه
ومصالح بلده وهذه المصالح تتعارض مع مصالح
الرئيس المصري والملك السعودي
والامارات وغيرهم هذا يعني محوله ملخصه
جدا
الموقف التركي وسياسات واشكركم والى لقاء
اخر
ام